bienvenidos de nuevo estamos ahora en la
sección número 8 del examen número 3
esta es la primera parte y empezamos en
la pagina 547 así que venga dice sí y es
el conjunto de enteros antes de poner
que es el problema número uno cambiamos
de herramienta y vamos a poner que es el
problema número uno el problema número
uno que dice sí y es el conjunto de
enteros pares p es el conjunto de
enteros positivos y f es el conjunto de
enteros menores que 5 cuál de los
siguientes incisos me da un número que
está en estos tres conjuntos es decir lo
que buscamos es la intersección de estos
tres conjuntos para ver si alguno de mis
incisos está en esta intersección
realmente lo que estamos buscando son
números que sean pares números que sean
pares
a su vez sean positivos pares positivos
positivos y que sean menores que cinco
menores menor que cinco ok y qué
opciones tengo dice el inciso 6 inciso 6
y esta no es mi respuesta porque 6 no es
menor que 5 por lo tanto el inciso a nos
sirve el inciso b es 4 veces 4 perfecto
este funciona el sisbén es 4 porque 4
spam es positivo y es menor que 5 este
funciona bastante bien
vamos a realizar los demás para no
quedarnos con la curiosidad dice que ese
es uno que es uno no es par por lo tanto
no me sirve de cero pero no es un número
positivo es el número de neutro
y es menos dos menos dos es un número
que no es positivo por lo tanto la
opción correcta es ver y vamos a hacer
aquí el problema número dos que dice
tengo la ecuación 8 más raíz
camps la raíz de camps y esto es igual a
15 lo que me preguntan es el valor de
campo así que esencialmente hay que
resolver esta ecuación y para esto voy a
restar 8 de ambos lados de esta ecuación
menos 8 menos 8 de tal manera que éste y
éste se van y me queda que la raíz de
camps es exactamente lo mismo que 15
menos 8 de los cuales 7 y ahora voy a
llevar a ambos lados de esta ecuación al
cuadrado de tal manera que me va a
quedar que camps es igual a 7 elevado al
cuadrado por lo tanto camps es igual a
49 ya está aquí tengo la respuesta de
este problema número 2 y vamos a hacer
el problema número 3 venga problema
número 3 dice en una encuesta se
entrevistaron a varias personas sobre su
postura para crear una nueva biblioteca
si 35 respondieron que estaban de
acuerdo y déjenme apuntarlo 35
respondieron estar de acuerdo
treinta y cinco respondieron que sí ok
catorce contestaron estar en desacuerdo
catorce dice que no y una persona
contestó de manera indiferente una
persona no sabe no sabe entonces lo que
nos preguntan es qué porcentaje de los
encuestados totales está a favor de la
construcción de la biblioteca
bueno pues eso está muy fácil porque lo
que hay que hacer es primero ver cuántos
están a favor de la construcción de la
biblioteca y 35 personas están a favor
de que si se construya esta nueva
biblioteca entonces me voy a tomar 35
entre la cantidad de encuestados totales
pero la cantidad de encuestados totales
es 35 más 14
y entonces esto es lo mismo que 35 / a
15 35 es 50 y de aquí puedo sacar quinta
arriba y quinta abajo y entonces si
divido entre 535 me da 7 y si divido 50
entre 5 me da 10 ya están si lo quiero
un porcentaje esto es lo mismo que el
70% o dicho de otra manera es el inciso
7 decimos perfecto ya está aquí la
respuesta de este problema número 3 así
que vamos a hacer el problema número 4
el problema número 4 y tiene una serie
de líneas muy parecidas a éstas así que
déjame hacer la figura la figura es algo
así
perfecto y después por acá se cruza algo
perfecto y después por aquí se cruza
algo así y después sube esto por acá
perfecto es como un corcho psicodélico
algo raro y dicen que este ángulo vale
30 grados este ángulo vale 30 grados
este otro vale 70 grados esto equivale
70 grados
este vale de grados mientras que este
balde 1 grados grados y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale tema zoom lo
que quiero saber es cuánto vale t más y
bueno para encontrar temas um hay que
pensar en triángulos tenemos los tres
puntos tenemos los triángulos am aquí
vale 30 grados aquí vale 70 grados y
estos ángulos están adentro de este
triángulo de este de aquí y si están
adentro de este triángulo entonces
cuánto vale este ángulo bueno pues este
ángulo es lo mismo que 70 más 30 estos
son 100 grados a 100 grados cuando le
falta para llegar a 180 grados bueno
pues nos faltan 180 grados 80 grados muy
bien y después date cuenta que estos dos
ángulos son opuestos si éste vale 80
grados este también va a valer 80 grados
cuando se interceptan estas dos líneas
estos dos ángulos son opuestos y
entonces valen lo mismo y ahora fíjate
que aquí tenemos otro triángulo
triángulos triángulos traigo los
triángulos aquí tengo otro triángulo
y éste esté perfecto y este y lo que yo
sé es que la suma de todos los ángulos
de un triángulo es 180 grados por lo
tanto de grados más grados más 80 grados
la suma de estos tres de este este y
este debe de ser igual a 180 grados y de
aquí puede despejar al tema azul de más
uno es igual a 100 grados a 100 grados
de grados más su grados es igual a 100
grados y ya está la respuesta de este
problema son 100 grados que por cierto
es el inciso c es el inciso sem y está
de lujo así que como vamos bien en
tiempo vamos a resolver más problemas
déjame borrar la pantalla ya me pongo
una nueva y voy a resolver ahora el
problema número uno dos tres cuatro
cinco problema número cinco
igual hay una gráfica enorme
a ver qué me dice el problema acorde a
la gráfica siguiente cuáles son los dos
años consecutivos donde hubo el mayor
cambio en el precio del café y creo que
si es necesario hacer la gráfica para
que veas lo que yo estoy viendo así que
déjenme hacer aquí la gráfica de una
manera muy rápida
algo así y después que años tengo tengo
el año de 1981 81 por aquí tengo 82 es
del 81 de 86 81 82 83 84 85 y por aquí
están 86 muy bien y después tengo
precios tengo desde 3.5 hasta 4.75
por aquí tengo 3.5 3.5 aquí tengo 3.75
3.75 por acá tengo 44 pesos por acá
tengo 4 pesos con 25 centavos 425 por
acá tengo 4.5 o 4.5 y por acá tengo
cuatro puntos 75 que es el precio
marsé
y bueno vamos a verlos por años dice que
en el 81 tengo un precio de 3.75 aquí
tengo un precio de 3.75 o algo así muy
bien en el 82
tengo un precio de 3.5 aquí tengo un
precio de 3.5
algo así perfecto en el 83
tengo un precio de 425 aquí sube hasta
425 que es más o menos por aquí
algo más o menos así perfecto
y después tengo un cambio hasta 475
hasta 475 aquí va a cambiar hasta 475
que es el valor más grande que toma en
esta gráfica el precio del café algo por
aquí y después en el 85 tengo a 3.75
aquí tengo tres puntos 75 que es algo
como por aquí a más o menos o algo así y
por último en el 86 tengo 450 déjame
tomar otro color y en el 86 tengo 450
entonces vamos a hacerlo de 450 que es
más o menos por aquí
algo más o menos como por aquí perfecto
y entonces que nos preguntan acuerdo con
la gráfica siguiente cuáles son los dos
años consecutivos donde hubo el mayor
cambio en el precio del café pues vamos
a ver los cambios
de aquí y acá pues rubor este cambio y
este cambio es de desde el punto 75
hasta punto 5 es punto 25 este cambio es
de punto 25 después del 82 83 tengo este
cambio de aquí
este cambio de aquí hasta acá y bueno es
de 3.5 hasta a 4.25 lo cual es punto 75
puntos 75 después del 83 84 cambios de
aquí hasta acá y esto es un punto 5 esto
está fácil y después del 84 85 guau
tengo un cambio bastante grande tengo
este cambio de aquí hasta acá creo que
este va a ser el ganador este cambio que
es de 4.75
a 3.75 y bueno es el cambio de un peso
de un peso y por último del 85 al 86
tengo este cambio de camps que es de
3.75 pesos hasta 4.5 pesos lo cual es 25
puntos 75 tengo un cambio de punto 75
muy bien y lo que me preguntan es cuáles
unos años consecutivos que tienen el
mayor cambio y si te das cuenta el mayor
cambio se obtuvo del año 84 al año 85 el
precio del café se desplomó un peso
entero es el cambio más grande que hay
punto 25 puntos 75.5 un peso entero y
punto 75 por lo tanto el cambio más
grande que hay desde el año 84 al año 85
que es el inciso de la respuesta a este
problema es el inciso d y ya está
todo este trabajo arduo para un problema
tan sencillo
en fin movámonos al siguiente problema
el problema número 6
el problema número 6 y dice lo siguiente
y no tengo más gráficas para mí así que
vamos a trabajar con una gráfica más
tengo algo así concentrados a él
concentrado tengo algo así
parecido a esto después tengo aquí que
este es mi eje y este es mi eje x y
tengo aquí el valor de menos 2 por aquí
tengo el valor de menos 180 por aquí
tengo 1 y por aquí tengo al 2 muy bien y
arriba tengo por aquí al 1 este es el
valor de 1 y por aquí tengo al 2 este es
el valor de 2 y tengo una función muy
parecida a esta déjenme cambiar de color
tengo una función que de aquí
baja hasta acá
algo más o menos así después por aquí se
mantiene estable hasta acá después por
aquí suben otra vez
por acá algo así y después aquí sigue y
sigue y sigue y sigue muy bien y nos
dicen que esta es la función ye igual a
g de x esta es la función que iguala gdx
y lo que nos pregunta es cuál de los
siguientes valores en los incisos am es
un valor válido para camps si fedecam
xix edecán es igual a 1 y bueno lo que
yo quiero saber es para qué valores de x
gtx og de acá en este caso es igual a 1
fijémonos en esta nuestra gráfica que
tenemos aquí
para qué valores que de x es igual a 1
bueno pues para estos no aquí está el 1
aquí está el 1 y los valores que tocan
gtx con una altura de 1 pues son todos
estos de aquí todos estos de aquí son
los posibles valores que yo puedo tomar
tales que quede x sea igual a 1 es decir
me estoy fijando en este intervalo en
este intervalo de aquí hasta acá hasta
el 0 es decir me estoy tomando todo este
intervalo todo este intervalo para
cualquier valor que esté aquí que de x
vale 1
estoy fijándome en qué valores 7x vale
y bueno con todos los valores que estén
de 0 al menos 1 todos ellos si yo de
aquí subo hasta tocar la función g y
valores 1 es decir mi respuesta puede
ser menos 10 o cualquier valor
intermedio entre estos am así que vamos
a ver los incisos el inciso am me dice
menos 1.5 menos 1.5 está como por acá
por lo tanto éste no funciona g de menos
1.5
no es 1 el inciso p es 0.5 en negativo
menos punto 52.5 está por aquí y qué
crees sí aquí tengo a menos 0.5
cuando yo subo tocó a la función gtx en
el valor de 1 es decir kg de menos 0.5
esto es exactamente igual a 1 y este es
el inciso pm el inciso b me dice menos
0.5 y es justo
mi respuesta aquí está
ya estoy corriendo en tiempo así que no
creo terminar el siguiente problema por
aquí voy a dejar esta primera parte de
la sección número 8 del examen número 3
am cuídate mucho y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo